en el último vídeo hablamos un poco
sobre el sistema inmunitario y en este
vídeo nos enfocaremos en el sistema
inmunitario no específico o en dato
y los sub dividimos en dos tipos de
barrera la primera línea de defensa que
incluye la piel el ácido estomacal o la
acidez de los aceites en el exterior de
tu piel
estas son barreras naturales que no
permiten que las cosas ajenas al cuerpo
ingresen a él pero si llegan a entrar
tenemos la segunda línea de defensa la
cual sigue siendo no especifica y cuando
decimos no específica significa que no
es necesario saber el tipo de virus
proteína o bacteria simplemente si algo
se ve sospechoso se lo comen o lo matan
obtenemos una respuesta inflamatoria y
vamos a hacer un vídeo sobre la
respuesta inflamatoria una vez que
estudiamos con mayor profundidad el
sistema inmunitario
entonces tenemos la respuesta
inflamatoria que es sólo llevar las
cosas a donde está la acción y también
tenemos a los fagocitos que son células
que ingieren las cosas y como sabes
todos los fagocitos de los que hablamos
en el vídeo pasado son glóbulos blancos
o leucocitos vamos a escribirlo éstos
fagocitos y me refiero a las células
dendríticas a los macrófagos ya los
neutrófilos todos estos son glóbulos
blancos no son todos los tipos de
glóbulos blancos que hay pero que
hablaremos de ello después otro término
para referirnos a los glóbulos blancos
es leucocitos bueno esto no es
específico la primera línea de defensa
no te deja entrar pero si logras entrar
entonces la segunda línea de defensa te
dice oye te ve sospechoso te voy a comer
tengo receptores no sé qué tipo de virus
seas no sé si te he visto antes o no
pero
soy no específico y bueno esto existe en
muchas especies y tipos de organismos
pero lo realmente interesante es que el
sistema inmunitario específico es como
una nueva adaptación
de lo que vamos a hablar es del sistema
inmunitario específico de los seres
humanos en particular esta es la otra
clasificación también podemos pensarlo
como el sistema inmunitario adaptativo
seguramente has escuchado cosas como
esta tengo resistencia a tal bacteria o
a tal virus
eso es adaptativo y todo se basa en
exponerse a ciertas cosas y dentro del
sistema inmunitario hemos hablado un
poco de las moléculas presentadoras de
antígenos que hacen los fagocitos esto
juega un papel importante y aunque vamos
a entrar en más detalles después por
ahora no quiero confundirte los actores
principales aquí te llaman linfocitos
así que no debemos de confundirnos con
leucocitos ya que de hecho siguen siendo
helleu cocidos
estos son no específicos pero ambos son
glóbulos blancos los linfocitos son otro
tipo de glóbulos blancos o leucocitos
es pero esto no te confunda es un
diagrama un poco complejo pero quiero
que lo tengamos muy claro al hablar de
glóbulos blancos estamos hablando de un
conjunto de células cuando se intentó
por primera vez separar los componentes
de la sangre por centrifugación tenían
los glóbulos rojos que se asentaban en
la parte de abajo y después había en
medio una capa espumosa formada por
glóbulos blancos y en la parte de arriba
había fluido el plasma de la sangre una
parte acuosa de aquí es donde viene el
término glóbulos blancos pero aunque
éstos tienen papeles diferentes
interactúan entre sí
ahora los linfocitos pueden separarse en
linfocitos b comúnmente llamadas células
y linfocitos t llamados células t la ve
y late hacen referencia al lugar donde
se desarrollan primero se reconocieron a
los linfocitos b en las bolsas de
fabricio
por ello se llaman linfocitos b la bolsa
de fabricio es un órgano de las aves que
participa en su sistema inmunitario la p
proviene de bursa que es bolsa en latín
pero en el sistema inmunitario humano se
producen en la médula ósea por su parte
los linfocitos t empiezan en la médula
ósea pero maduran y se desarrollan en el
timo de allí proviene la tf en este
vídeo sólo nos enfocaremos en los
linfocitos b ya que nos enfocamos en
todo tendríamos un vídeo de una hora
pero a mí me gustan muchos los
linfocitos b no me gusta tener un
favorito pero algo en mi cerebro se
inclina por ellos los linfocitos b
participan en lo que se conoce como
respuesta moral
un moral no significa que sea gracioso
por su parte los linfocitos t participan
en lo que se conoce como inmunidad
celular y ciertas clases de estos
linfocitos participan en ella ya veremos
que el células t colaboradoras y células
t citotóxicas yo sé que es un poco
confuso la primera vez que lo ves y es
por ello que nos enfocaremos primero en
las células ve pero en un vídeo futuro
hablaremos sobre las células de
colaboradoras que desempeñan un papel en
la amplificación y activación de la
respuesta moral pero la forma de pensar
en la diferencia entre la respuesta
moral y la inmunidad celular es la
siguiente vamos a imaginar que fuimos
infectados por un virus estas dos son
células de nuestro cuerpo y al principio
cuando un virus entra en nuestro sistema
va a flotando por allí en los fluidos de
nuestro sistema
entonces la respuesta moral responde a
los fluidos morales del cuerpo si estos
son virus flotando por allí entonces
interviene la respuesta moral dado que
están flotando por allí y no están
quietos dentro de una célula lo mismo
pasa si tenemos una bacteria mientras
nos infiltren en las células y sólo
vayan flotando en los fluidos entonces
la respuesta moral será útil ahora si de
repente estos patógenos infiltran en las
células ahora las células estarán
infectadas con el virus y los virus usan
los mecanismos de la célula para
producir más entonces tendremos que ser
más sofisticados al tratar con estas
células y con estos virus porque ya no
sólo están flotando por allí
probablemente queremos matar
esta célula incluso aunque sea una de
las nuestras
ya que ahora ayuda a la propagación del
virus o tal vez esté colonizada por
bacterias
en cualquier caso necesitamos matarla y
por lo tanto interviene el proceso de
inmunidad celular del que hablaremos
después con más detalle